the Press of paparazzi's you know they
want to get the right shot they want to
get the right story but Public Safety
must always be at the Forefront of my
The Briefing I received you know two of
our offices could have been injured I
think all of us I don't think there's
many of us who don't recall how
uh how the his mom died and it would be
horrific to lose an innocent bystander
during a chase like this and something
to have happened to them as well so I
think we have to be extremely
responsible I thought that was a bit
Reckless and irresponsible
I would find it hard to believe that
there was a two-hour high-speed chase
that would be finding it hard to believe
but we will find out the exact duration
of it but if it's uh 10 minutes a 10
minute Chase is extremely dangerous in
New York City